milos forman jeune cinéaste tchèque est
venue pour 24 heures à paris il était
logique d'aller le trouvait au quartier
latin
avant d'y rencontrer son public il y a
découvert une atmosphère familière celle
de ses films
celle de son adolescence celle des rêves
de jeunesse qu'on fait à prague à paris
ou ailleurs quand on a 20 ans l'as de
pique les amours d'une blonde deux
titres de films qui ne disait rien en
français il y a seulement six mois ils
n'ont presque pas quitté la fiche depuis
on découvre avec surprise à jeune cinéma
tchèque qui ressemble étrangement au
nôtre
milos forman comment êtes vous venu au
cinéma alors j'ai commencé à penser à la
cinéma quand j'étais 13 14 15 ans et je
vous lis dans ce temps toujours épouser
les protagonistes féminines
j'ai vu à l'écran comme rita iron ou
chez morgan mania darrieux et j'ai pensé
qu' une seule solution
comment les épouses et comment réussir
ses détracteurs alors j'ai commencé à
jouer comme à terme et après quelqu'un
j'ai compris qu'il faut être le metteur
en scène est ce que vous avez réussi à
épouser une star non non gg épouse est
toujours là sophie près normal je
faisais ces premières film toujours
raison de venir
le star dans mon pays et mon quitté avec
les acteurs intervenant dans vos films
on a l'impression que vous utilisez
surtout des acteurs non professionnels
les deux jeunes celui de l'as de pique
le garçon qui est le héros de last hope
i et la jeune fille des amours d'une
blonde ne me semblent pas être des
acteurs très connus une espèce que je me
trouve
ouais ce sont les docteurs en nombre sur
leur monde
mais les autres aussi laid mais c'est
difficile de trouver en un peu
professionnelle dans quinze ans de l'âge
15 ans et les autres les adultes sont
sûrs les acteur non professionnel
c'est pourquoi c'est parce que quand
vous faites vos premiers furent j'ai eu
beaucoup de pères de peu d acteurs
professionnels parce que vous voulez
avoir les bons acteurs mais qui sont les
bons acteurs ils vous ont fait déjà dix
vingt cinquante films et il ils ont peur
de vous parce que ils ne savent rien de
vous
vous ferez vous faites au premier film
et ils ont peur que vous allez les
détruire ils vont vous dirigez ne vous
fait pas confiance que j'ai essayé quand
j'ai préparé le film j'ai je fais les
essais avec les acteurs professionnels
j'ai senti qu'il me manque pas cru
qu'ils vont me dirigeais que vont faire
les choses qu'ils croient qu'ils ne
croient pas alors c'était pas possible
alors c'est ce la raison pour projet
choisir les acteurs non professionnels
mais finalement j'ai trouvé les acteurs
non professionnels dans certains pans de
vie beaucoup plus intéressant que les
acteurs professionnels parce qu'ils sont
réels sommes dans vos deux films ce que
nous avons pu voir en france vous
traiter de problèmes d'adolescence
est-ce que vos film relate des souvenirs
de ces périodes là où est ce que le
conflit des générations vous intéresse
comme problème en tant que problème
alors j'aime ce tonnage formidable
l'adolescente
c'est un âge dans laquelle la dérive
mans en français distance la différence
la différence entre les experts et
l'expérience et les aider à les idéal
c'est différent c'est la plus
passionnant l'appli touchant dans cet
âge est aussi l'air les relations entre
les générations sont je pense que c'est
la crise en paix dans les relations
entre les fils et ses pairs aujourd'hui
que si les relations sont mis alors nous
les adultes nous pensons en paix
coupable que le monde en général
cette pas encore mieux qu'il ait dit mme
à milos forman quels sont les cinéastes
que vous préférez
commençons par les cinéastes moderne si
vous voulez français non français
italiens russes que vous voulez
j'aimerais savoir un peu quels sont les
signes à ce que vous préférez ou que
vous aimez mais sans les préférées
tellement aux autres alors j'aime
beaucoup de transsene mai
je préfère par exemple jean vigo j'adore
cet enjeu ni moderne
je trouve j'aime beaucoup le noir de
nouvelles lois françaises m
pas tous mais le jem
il faudrait godard j'aime bien les
cinéastes anglais certains ont trouvé
que vos films relev ait un fait du
néoréalisme italien à cause de cette
partie de documentaires est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ces définitions de ne
réalise alors moi moi j'aimais beaucoup
les films de néo réalisme italien
il y à la barre les manières de films
documentaires la voix mais moi je pense
que les firmes de néo réalisme ce sont
les films montés à la thèse
moi je préfère les films à l'accueil il
y avait eu votre film quelque chose de
très original c'est que la bande sonore
enfin la musique provoque le plan
la plupart du temps la musique
accompagne un plan soit est inutile et
bien chez vous elle elle précède
vraiment le grain de la tonalité howey
moi j'aime bien utiliser pour le film la
musique qui était déjà composer je
n'aime pas beaucoup la musique est
composée spécialement pour film et ce
sont les raisons ci si j'ai la musique
déjà avant le tournage je peux me
laisser provoquer de sa musique surtout
l'écouté chaque jour et la deuxième
raison c'est qu'ils sont allés sont les
enfants terribles et compositeur il
compose en plus par les meilleures
choses sans raison si vous voulez
spécialement composé quelque chose très
bon jamais vous me comprenez
[Musique]